does anybody have any opinion on general
milly do we want to cover that god yeah
sure okay so let's go through it since
we got eight minutes left so
general milley fear trump might launch
nuclear attack made secret calls to
china new book says usa today in the
aftermath of january 6 attack on u.s
capital joint chief of staff chairman
general mark milley then the former
president trump's top military advisor
took precautions to limit trump's
ability to launch a military strike or
deploy nuclear weapons according to a
new book by bob woodward who's always
talking about this stuff and robert
costa the washington post in a rare move
millie called the secret meeting of
senior military officials at the
pentagon on january to review the
process of military action including
launching nuclear weapons he instructed
those in charge of the national military
commander center the pentagon's war room
not to take orders from anyone without
his involvement
mili also reassured uh chinese general
lee zhu cheng of the people's
libertarian army that the u.s had no
intention of launching an airstrike
against china it was one of two secret
phone calls shared by lee on the issue
zenner thoughts you know it just goes to
gerard's point that uh think of the
average intelligence person you know and
assume that 50 of the people are dumber
than that if you believe this crap
you're an idiot you're a flat out idiot
if you think donald trump was thinking
of a nuclear war on january 6 who the
hell was he going to attack new jersey i
mean who would be in the crosshairs of
our of an attack you know it's one thing
if you don't like him but you don't have
to you know paint him as a buffoon or
someone that would launch a nuclear
weapon on his final week in office
meanwhile eric swalwell from california
actually threatened nukes against
american citizens yeah and you know it's
just so blatantly obvious that this is
an end run to take the attention off
afghanistan i mean you either have
common sense or you don't i'd like to
think i have a little bit and that's the
only way i see this story by the way
some people on the opposing side are
saying what an honorable thing to do to
take the responsible position to make
the phone call to prevent him from doing
what he did adam what are your thoughts
about this
i i think um you can't have it both ways
because we have two stories here on the
list
one based on this book peril from uh bob
woodward and robert costa and if you
don't know who robert costa is the guy
is a total g he sat down there he's
interviewed trump bob woodward
yes yeah correct
we all know woodward but you know if you
know costa yeah so they're telling this
story and then we have a story on the
other page where basically they called
out
biden about him calling out a mansion so
do you either believe that actually read
the story read the read the part
biden told joe manchin to support his
1.9 trillion coronavia stimulus
because if you don't come along you're
really [ __ ] me the book says
that's what biden's sister manchester
yes okay so
you want me to keep going no no you can
go back to the point you were making the
point is this so
tom says he doesn't believe it all right
so do you believe this point though
you can't you
automatically assume everything he says
is true or false i choose to believe
that i don't think donald trump was
thinking of launching nuclear weapons on
january sure okay wait wait wait wait
wait we're both missing the point are
you saying you're thinking he was about
to launch i don't think so oh i don't
think he was about talking about it i do
think that he was after the the day he
lost or after the january 6th
i do think to use some of the words that
they used he was angry okay erratic
emotional potentially unstable and
unpredictable was he nuking people i
don't think so
speaking of track record let's talk
about one predictable in this case means
not doing what we want him to do
because that if you want to look at the
parallels to your point if you want to
look at the parallels between the two
stories joe manchin is saying no i'm not
giving you 3.5 trillion dollars
back in march because it's not now so
what i'm saying is that but he's still
saying no to three five came out now but
this is okay you listen to what we tell
you to do also guys
with all due respect we're getting stuck
in the minutia here this is the top
general in the united states of america
going behind an elected official duly
elected official going behind who
represents the citizens
he had just lost like but he didn't
leave office he was still appreciative
he was the president united states this
guy's calling our number one if you
don't want to use the word enemy our
number one competitor on the world scale
behind the back of the people if a
general did that to biden would you have
an issue the general did that
absolutely not at all but generally
dude that's okay are you kidding me no
no no by the way if a general did that
to biden democrats would put that guy
and his wife and his kids in jail for
the rest of their lives
what are we doing here though this is
the very evidence of a deep state this
idea of the he's a hero this is the very
end it depends on your perspective yeah
and it's shocking that the military is
this involved how is this a matter of
perspective was he do you do you think
there was a chance chance
i'm using the word chance gerard
president there was a chance that he was
that erratically the elected official he
was more worried about
president twitter
people can't hear when we're screaming
just so you know
first of all
if a situation like that happens the
general makes one phone call you don't
call the enemy you don't ever call the
enemy who does the general call dude
like the last if there's if there's 50
000 numbers on who to call you know what
the last number is to call china why
would you call china
i agree why was he calling china that's
the point what are you doing now now let
me explain to you what could have been a
different thing to do here's what it
could have been a different thing to do
he calls pence fine i get it
he calls
his wife i get it
he calls his daughter i get it
he calls kellyanne conway i get it
he calls anybody he calls kushner fully
get it those calls listen trump would
still lose his mind but i understand
those calls this one phone call i don't
get and i don't support that one you've
been in the military do you think he
called chuck could that happen what's
the reason behind it it's it's it's
because for him
he probably got a phone call from
somebody saying hey
if i'm going to be president my name is
biden biden called millie who said call
china to say don't worry i'm not going
to do anything to them well it says here
in the article something different what
it says mili also reassured chinese
general lee zoo chang that the people's
liberation army that the u.s had no
intention of launching a strike against
china it was one of two secret phone
calls so someone in china was probably
like dude how erratic
just happening
here's what they think i'm reading the
article i'm telling you somebody called
millie yeah to tell millie to call china
millie didn't do this on the zone so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]